let's be blunt it will take centuries to
terraform Mars Mars is a gigantic planet
roughly on the order of half the size of
the planet Earth
the key is not to bring pumps to the
planet Mars because it costs too much
money the way to do it is to take
advantage of Mars's own topology
geography and nature you need the
surface of Mars and lots of carbon
dioxide if you could heat up the planet
a little bit that will release carbon
dioxide and initiate a greenhouse effect
which will then melt more ice and let
more carbon dioxide come up so in other
words you have an autocatalytic effect
you just have to jumpstart it once you
jumpstart it more carbon dioxide creates
more temperature heats up the planet
which releases more carbon dioxide so
then the question is how do you
jumpstart it a number of mechanisms have
been proposed greenhouse effects
hydrogen bombs nuclear power plants to
raise the temperature of Mars a little
bit and that will then set off a chain
reaction release even more carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere that's the
cheapest way to take advantage of the
carbon dioxide that already exists
rather than hauling pumps and generators
from the earth to Mars